you know many of these meteorites are
billions of years old
imagine you holding that in your hand
the earliest part of the solar system
it feels
[Music]
amazing name is naveen jan and i'm an
entrepreneur
i started the collection about five
years ago and many people would say that
i probably do have the largest
collection of meteorites in private
hands
when you look at this stuff and people
say it's just a rock until you see in
the microscope and say oh my god what
you have really in your hand is the
space gems
i am just such a curious person
so when you holding a piece of moon in
your hand it's not just a piece of moon
it really is symbolic of what we as
humans are which are explorers
when we get inspired what do we do we
look up every star that we see
is really one square inch of our own
galaxy
so when something falls on earth we have
no idea what body it came from
this is a great meteorite this has 20
plus amino acids so it's quite likely
these amino acids became the foundation
for who we are today so when someone
says we're looking for aliens all we
have to do is look around us we all
could be aliens
this is a great you right but the white
stuff that you see is the earliest part
of our universe and many of these things
are formed at the time of the big bang
there is no doubt in my mind the space
is going to be a next frontier and it's
very simple reason every single thing
that we value on earth
is an abundance in space we are just
nothing but a tiny pale blue dot
[Music]
you